in polygamous societies the strongest
men take all the women are the ever
woman cheats she knows that the
relationship is finished the only time
the relationship's truly done is when
the woman says it's done so then either
you put a ring on this or I'm gone
that's it if I love that man I will
definitely uh sex with him whenever he
wants because I want it honestly no
honestly I'm gonna I'm gonna ask you
something then
um it happened to me to have many
friends they actually prefer like date
older yeah
may I make the point men are trying to
kill at 20 years old girl as a 15 years
old woman that's not different they are
thinking just to
I don't want to be rude but like you
know what I mean they are thinking about
that from the principle so if uh old
women get you know less attractive
whatever it is so anyway that's quite
good looking 15 years old women that
they actually dating 20 or 30 years old
man
like honestly me personally I add
friends very good look six foot guys
very good looking guys they actually
dated older women also child did they
marry them what did they do they it
doesn't count unless you get a ring for
me like that doesn't know what I'm
saying it doesn't count unless he
commits to you for life so yeah
six years old give him the time to get
married
I did a guy that was a millionaire does
that mean make me
no no no yeah
results the results so first of all
that's not the result for myself because
I uh 20 years old women who can get
married when she's 22 so she's so
valuable or whatever she got a lot of
eggs she can be left alone when she is
25 and the husband is sleeping around
around and gonna left her alone looking
after the child so what about the value
we're talking about she's still 25 she
give you a best life her best sister
is she is by herself now so what about
this what about this go ahead and say
why don't you get married before she had
the kid no no I said you getting a 20
years old women with lot of eggs you
know beautiful and then everything so
very you know
not childless okay so you get married
with that you get you got a pregnant so
let's say you got one child or whatever
now how many cases we know about men
leaving the house with the child
children oh men still cheating on them
cheating about the value guys if she was
available so why it went outside to
looking for others because because
cheating is different for men and for
women men can have sex with the phone
and what about when they leave the
cheese
no they don't know
women women women
stop yelling stop stop you you just were
yelling okay women leave 70 to 80
percent of the time 90 if you have a
college degree 90 of the time you're
leaving Man
by and large are not leaving so that's
not who do you men and women cheat at
equal rates I'm talking about I a lot of
lot of children left alone from Day Dad
okay I know a lot of single mothers and
they've been left alone okay you can you
can know it but you can look at who
files a divorce the difference
but the difference from what she's
saying
is that the big difference is what you
said that he married her yeah that gives
her status who cares if he's sleeping
out she's covered if she goes I get
married that's what I was gonna say
thank you
guys the man sorry Auntie Jenny just
give me one second guys I'm gonna
reiterate the rules because we're not
getting there one at a time people at
home can't hear you it's a great
conversation I want you guys to have
this conversation but I need to be able
to hear you so please allow each other
to speak one at a time thank you let's
get into it you got
a young girl you say 25 with a kid
and the mama is a loser goes and sleeps
out you got a 25 yeah yeah you got a 25
year old woman
not married the man has a kid with a
loser who's at the better advice the one
that got married
because she can take everything because
they're making everything about status
and what Society think about women
that's like me saying I'm an Olympian
with no metal
like like women live like this is what I
mean like you're like that's delusion go
through life living in delusion
okay
if I if I have a ring then I am
protected I if I I okay okay your mic is
off because you keep interrupting me if
I have a ring that I'm entitled like
then I'm protected legally I'm protected
legally if you don't from from you okay
do you not do you not know League
sorry but if he you can turn it on go
ahead oh I was on mute this whole time
okay but if if he if he's cheated on you
like a 20 year old he's married her
she's young she's got eggs whatever dude
he's married her they've had vowels
they've had a child and he's cheated
she's okay because she's got a ring he's
racist
especially because he married her that's
what's the most okay
I haven't finished sorry so so you said
that there was the 20 year old who got
married had a baby and he cheated and
then you got the 25 year old who had a
baby but didn't get married and he
cheated or let's just say they're both
the same age right right the one that
had a ring is more special because she
got a ring she's more protected okay
she's protected by law because his
husband
yeah exactly so like let's say so so
because sorry I hadn't finished so
because she's protected by the ring that
makes her more valuable because she's
got the medal let's be real less results
oh sorry I haven't said no but you
stopped and then you say I haven't
finished no because you come in and
didn't let me finish okay go on so then
sorry I've just you just said the result
was the ring but the result was he she
got cheated okay cool okay allowed to
finish a lot all right cool no it's just
like they're both they're they're both
at a loss it's not one is better than
the other they're both equal okay well
it's not no no no it's not equal this is
my point so one's protected so because
she got married she's protected by the
law because of the yeah
can we be real about life I'm just
taking it and I'm not disagreeing I'm
not saying it to make it clear so if
we're being clear about life like you
said we have two women in identical
positions but one is married and one is
not if you're not married and it all
goes pear-shaped you're gone honestly
nothing you can't go nowhere and say
well he cheated on me I should get half
sorry love you're not married forget
about it if you're married you're
entitled yeah yeah in life let's be real
you're getting half okay cool I've been
cheated on emotionally you might be sad
for a bit but again as they say do you
want to cry in a Bentley or in a theater
okay
you want to get cheated on and go and
stay go back home to your mum or stay in
a room with your friends never or do you
want to get the house
talking first and men look at and men
look at Ex-Wives and ex-girlfriends
different okay man look at Ex-Wives and
ex-girlfriends different because because
one has results and they can say oh that
man chose her she was worth being chosen
where a girl that's that's over a
certain age they're like why nobody
choose you because I know other guys
aren't stupid so why didn't anyone
Choose You So then the two women that
were both 20 years old that got cheated
on 25 or whatever and then one was
married one wasn't if now they're both
30 and in that 10 years they were so
heartbroken couldn't date anyone else
they're now 30 with a child one was
married one wasn't you would go for the
pardon they're left over then pudding
left over so no so you want to go for
either of them okay why are you getting
divorce for when you got married why are
you getting divorcedure I just said
nothing
situations
no I said both were 20 one was married
one wasn't they both had a child each
one they both were cheated on and then
after 10 5 10 years or whatever now
they're ready to date again because they
couldn't date when they had a young baby
or whatever now the charge is five six
seven eight years old too young today
and they're sorry that's too young
what's Too Young have you got a child
five years old and you've been married
oh you guys are adding extra stuff like
just I'm trying to get to your reality
from reality
now that the the two women that one was
20 both were 20 one was married one
wasn't whatever they've now come to 26
27 8 whatever years old you're saying
that the one that was married that
divorced she's more valuable than the
one that wasn't I'm just trying to yeah
so and you would date the one that so
you would still go for that one with a
child who was divorced
can we stop acting like like men are out
here cheating all the time the majority
of them
I'm saying I'm saying the majority of
men aren't even having sex
guys wait and the wait wait and the
number one reason for divorce is
financial reasons
he's going off the conversation that was
happening before you gave a scenario of
two women one both 21 one divorce one
dealer yeah
trying to make another Point like if the
men got the most valuable women ever
because she was young pretty whatever
why they still
leave those women if they are they do
they do because I know quite a lot of
single mother so they've been left alone
so for those single mothers they've been
left alone been left alone the man leave
or did they choose the men the men the
men yeah
I like honestly speaking like I am very
close I am very close no very close
relationship also like people that I
know very closely that like they coming
from a divorced parents and she was the
first like she was the Virgin we're
talking about he had two children and
then after he left for Waffle honestly
speaking so like what we talking about
man anyway can get even the best women
ever the most valuable that we're
talking about whatever in our best she
can give him her Best Buy
by and large it's not true the women are
leaving it's not men okay
you're I honestly I came next time I'm
gonna come with number two so probably
I'm gonna improve my the stories that
you have are probably the exception the
huge that's quite a lot there's quite a
lot of single patterns single mother
quite a lot yeah quite a lot probably
like 15 15 or more a lot yeah and that's
a of my new amount to the whole thing
and so what they're saying is I see more
divorce divorced couples
in your in your circle would you say men
left more than women yeah definitely
from people that you know yeah men of us
more than women yeah yeah a lot of women
don't feel to realize is
how hard it is for a man to get married
in the first place but not take that
lightly may not take it lightly and I
don't think they realize the importance
that every man decides to put a ring on
your finger he can have 15 women out
there he decided to put a ring on your
finger that means something because
marriage does not come easy to manage
command decides that's who I'm gonna
marry that puts you up there wherever
you think Webbie's got 15 women or not
but that person out there because
they're married men are risking losing
everything like men men
no men are risking ruin their ruining
their entire life if they marry you
because you can leave take half their
[__] and take the kids with you and then
they have to pay you to take their kids
yeah because they don't even mind
probably about their children sometimes
is that is that what you think of man
some of them yes because if you want to
build a real relationship you gonna
you're gonna look for someone that
actually can deal with everything and
when I'm saying everything I don't mean
cheating because loyalty is actually on
the basement of every relationship men
have lost their entire life savings
trying to get custody of their kids from
mothers that I know because like me
personally I know but I had two brothers
and they've been they coming from the
first my my dad first marriage so I know
quite well so I'm talking about
something that I actually be involved
during my life so I know what I'm
talking about and I'm saying that's
that's such a high risk for a guy so if
a guy is putting a real willing to put a
ring on your finger that means something
like you just took actually the right uh
example because like my dad had two
children from a woman who was the Virgin
we're talking about she was 18 years old
when she met my dad and they had two two
children and the marriage end up right
and my dad actually fight to you know
see the children all right so you see
even though she was the most like I mean
obviously considering your standard so
your standard guys she was a very
valuable girl but anyway the marriage
end up and who win I will say no one
definitely my brothers they suffer quite
a lot but she didn't win because she had
the ring because after my dad married
another my mother and then then she kept
it actually actually yeah that's that's
horrible yeah this is horrible win so
she won because she had the ring who won
in this story
did she just means she won more than the
girl who never got the ring it doesn't
mean she won in life the one who wins is
the one yeah
the one who wins is the one who gets
married and stays married no I I think
she had a very very sad life because you
know when you get that angry to take
your children from your ex-usband you
having a very hard time you have enough
very sad life even though you got the
ring you got [__] you got [__] okay so
um I do you want to get married but I'm
gonna read the super chats real quick so
I'm gonna take a second to do that and
then you can ask that quite you can be
the first one to ask a question if you
guys have to go to the bathroom um feel
free to go now also they're probably
going to be mean I'm just warning you
okay um seppa saying sketch lady in the
middle doesn't know what the best number
one woman in her eyes not is not in
men's eyes ask the men in the middle how
many friends she has mgtow by Logic
Italia you think that all men sheep
because you only sleep with men in the
top 20 percent of men yeah we in the top
20 percent of the men don't know what we
want do know do what we want not what
you want but that doesn't mean the other
eighty percent of men behave as badly as
you do you're delusional um drazy and
gaming God please come back to me when
you talk to please don't come back
talking to you middle one
um actually okay guys I'm gonna do over
over ten dollar super chats just because
there's so many I don't think I can get
through them
maybe yeah over ten dollars okay alter
void stop the lies you know single women
that lie about being left the truth they
they just know now they've [__] up and
they need to be the victim and you're
lying to and your friends are lying to
you
um vudoki to be fair I don't know any
married men that cheat on a wife that
makes his sexual needs a priority if
that's accurate and accurate
generalization then when a man cheats
who who really broke the valve first oh
that's a good point
um Voodoo key to my ideal woman
attractive fit affectionate part-time
job at most Homemaker well I work 70
hours a week making good money is that
chauvinistic sounds like pretty laid
back life for a woman to me uh
the next 10 one okay Matt butcher women
need to hear some anti-geny wisdom at 14
it would solve x Exton this exponential
world problems
um silly sausage they don't get it did
anyone actually ask her to start stating
everything that has about that they
don't get it did anyone actually ask her
to start stating everything that is
valuable about herself no one asked you
to put up your personal trauma walls
don't move the goal post with emotion
light cake for Mr ever the woman in the
middle is going to die alone with no
family all men don't care about how much
money you make have fun with that and
ask yourself when you're all alone
having your fun Matt butcher this is
great we get to see the effects of
feminism on full to display real time
what to watch out for mgtow by Logic can
a man stand by you no man wants to stand
by you that's the point of everyone is
telling you wake up your value to a man
is plummeting hourly listen to Auntie or
Die Alone
um Bane Cheers Cheers Pearl keep it in
line ten dollars from the blackest
Panther are we surprised that 30 year
old women are disagreeable and annoying
men do not care about your experience
the more experience a woman has the more
baggage she has and the lower her value
is to other men mgtel by Lodge at fifty
dollars Super Chat
the buyer determines the value always
men or the buyer just like you determine
what you value in men you don't date
bums do you know stop shaming men you
are 30 and alone you better listen to
Anthony you've already wasted 12 years
um TG love love love Auntie also Pearl
if you want to experience the ultimate
red pill look up Yuri Ben something and
our call is going to be allowed I'll be
down from the Chicago area black is
Panther it's not hard to tell a woman
with a high body count combination of
these frequently wants to go on girls
trips bars and clubs or has high alcohol
areas constantly on social media for
attention
um the next is ten dollars Mr Mt
lavadier hello from Colorado USA I live
in the mountain ski town all the girls
here are ran through please help I I
literally can't help you
um
Condor mayenda y'all be really putting
in the red pill red pill work for eight
hours straight and then I'm going to
refresh it real quick
um okay so you you said you had a
question you wanted to ask yeah but all
right
um oh actually there's one there's one
more Super Chat
um CV boy God my girl really hated that
I started watching you yeah don't don't
tell your girlfriends
um go ahead no my question was
um like who actually wants to get
married and why
um yeah that was my main question
um
he wants to get married in a way in what
regardless no I was asking the men do
you want to get married if God says yes
then why if it's no then why I
personally still believe that marriage
is quite beautiful
um I know it's a risk because as we've
called with the statistics most women
end up leaving but I still think it
probably plays back to my my upbringing
I just feel like marriage is just a
natural Next Step
um in the progression of a relationship
so you do you want to get I would love
to get an idea so
but I also offering to add on to that to
that marriage is more beneficial for
society because even throughout history
if you look at that polygamous Society
it's one of the things that they see
that's prevalent is there's a lot of
like great there's a lot of crime
because
in polygamous societies the strongest
men take all the women which these other
men to revolt and cause problems so
monogamy is actually beneficial to say
keeps women safe it makes Insight by and
large more better nuclear family homes
lead to less um
traumatic experiences for children so
you can see there's a lot of benefits
through marriage so yeah there's
all right but you'd actually didn't
really answer the question like why you
want to get mad you why you want to get
this beautiful thing okay you already
said that beautiful yes
physical advantage over that being in a
situation where you're not married yes
so why would like what so it's more
beneficial for kids
children now right it will be beneficial
uh it will be yeah yeah so no the point
I was trying to get at is if like if you
have a reason for why you want to get
married they don't and you believe in
marriage and the vows that you've made
whether it's the god or wherever then
why would you then go against those
vowels and cheat and then it's for some
reason it's okay first of all I haven't
cheated no no I'm just because the guys
have left and they were here before
we're gonna ask them no no I hear what
you're saying but
I hate what you're trying to do I hate
what you're trying to say but you have
to remember and we've mentioned this
before that married although marriage is
what sought after and it's more
beneficial for our Offspring one the
reason I seek marriage is because it's
better for my kids to be raising a
nuclear family but even though it's
still it's still it's marriage is still
not my biological imperative I have to
sacrifice elements of mice biological
being to conform to the female standard
if I had my way I'd have my woman that I
love and it's women that just chop hid
now and again if I had my way but to
conform to the social standards of
society
I try to be in a monogamous situation I
don't aspire to be a man that cheats
however anything that hasn't happened is
just a prediction of the future do you
get what I'm saying yeah and I think
most people put it that way so I'm just
saying this look if you've got a good
man
and he steps out once in like once or
twice in 40 years listen the grass isn't
green until you water it the grass ain't
green on the other side so I think
that's the thing that women have to
recognize does that work both ways of
course not
okay because men can love multiple women
at the same time or women can only love
my own man and if she's if she's
cheating on you you don't love him no
but you you use an example yeah could
you just walk out now see a guy that you
attracted to you and say listen go [__]
me in the corner right now could you do
that so could you could you do that for
me personally I couldn't most women most
women couldn't yeah so most people don't
want to behave like that you see a man
if he sees a girl he's attracted to you
I will bang you in the bush I'll bang in
the street corner it don't matter it is
what it is but that's the that's the
fundamental difference so so why it
can't be flipped around is because it
takes more food to allow someone in
whereas for a man it's like taking a
piss so that's why it's different but
why is it acceptable no I don't think
he'd get one from and say why is he
accepted no because if if a woman cheats
yeah there's a reason behind why she's
cheating of course so then why is it
that if she cheats you can't just accept
it it's because it goes beyond sex
there's the emotions involved that for a
woman to let a guy in there's a process
it's premeditated it's never just a slip
up for a man it's literally I wasn't
using my head and I had a nut to bust
and that's that's all it is but for you
it goes further than that okay but what
if it was a slip up if it was a girl
that's not a slipper I might bending you
over blasting your back yeah she's on
holidays that's premeditated you've gone
on that holiday I want wanting to [__]
her brother out there
if you love a man if you love a man
you're not looking if you really love
him man you're not you're not looking at
anyone else you only see him you're not
listening to what I'm saying I said if
you are in a situation where you're
married and your woman slipped up and
just one time she slept for someone just
on holiday you know what uh do you know
what I think you're doing yeah and
you're trying to use the exception to
that no that is because most women
wouldn't behave most women aren't
slipping up giving a scenario in that
scenario I'd like to think but it can
never happen I would just fall and die
if I hear that my immune system will
shut down I'll just get covered and I'll
pass away okay
by holistically that's not how women
behave so how am I supposed to assume
that this is just a slip up and not
something more how can I make that Helen
I'm telling you yeah I'm giving you a
situation no and I hear what your
situation is saying but I'm saying as a
man
I can't assume that that is the case I
have to assuming that the answer is no
you wouldn't take it out no of course
not
100 because you know because you should
know that me slipping up is literally
just slipping up you letting a man in
it's not it's not because you said it
yourself you couldn't just let a man
slip into a Tonton like that I said me
personally and most women
situation if he was dating me you can't
slip up like that I'm sorry
I'm saying I'm giving you an actual
scenario where she slipped up she went
on holiday she had a hot girl oh yeah
and then she just had a bit too much to
drink one thing led to another she just
one night stand or I didn't it meant
nothing it was just a slip up
and then would you take her back yeah
can I just say that women can I just say
that women cheat right women she it got
no it's just it got nothing to do with
life I understand that when women oh
then when men cheat it's a one-off when
we mean she the relationship is finished
think that you've I agree and 100. what
I'm trying to say is that how many women
are the ever woman cheats she knows that
the relationship is finished
nine times out of ten at the woman
cheats that's the end of it that's the
end of her relationship that's true but
as ever Man Cheats it's not the end or
to put it as my mum will say it
men have all their bits on the outside
because they can flick it around
everywhere God hid the women's away
because it's hard to find internal so if
you're gonna go and give it away like
that there's a lot to go through for a
man to get to you internally rather just
on the outside because women are The
Gatekeepers of sex or even more but even
more than that you have to think but the
point guys is like it's not about the
man which is coming back and every time
we know that you're probably gonna sleep
around and come back home the point is
what about us like how do we do you
think that not actually you know
as an impact on your marriage do you
think she gonna be fine no knowing that
you actually eat other
[Applause]
you can go after I'm done okay it men
and women aren't the same and so a man
can have sex with a hole in the wall
they don't care a woman a woman if she
sleeps with some a man he has to be
someone we are not sleeping with bums
out there unless he looks like Michael B
Jordan that is it again like I asked
everyone individually would you get
married and why I lost him individually
would you take a woman back if she
slipped up and it was just a one and
done thing and it was Michael B Jordan
and it was like she had a chance to
would you take her back
Okay so
should a woman take a man back if he
cheats no she shouldn't does she yes
that is not our choice as we are saying
men and women are different if you speak
to women I've spoken to a lot of women
yeah and when they say to me oh
um my relationship ended because my man
was cheating yeah the first thing I say
to them is what did he cheat once and
then you left and they said no he was
cheating is never he cheated it's always
he was cheating which meant this dude
has decided he is going to continue
sleeping with other women but when did
she find out it was women number one and
then it was oh no no no no my point is
you are not going to go out and find a
woman who says I went I was going out
with this dude he cheated on me once and
I left you don't it doesn't happen if
women if women don't like being cheated
yeah exactly even so yeah even though on
your point yeah if I was to take this
woman back do you think she'll ever
respect me so you she's gonna go she's
gonna go sit in the next man's face for
banner and what a woman's a look
if if you because you have to remember a
lot of relationships are predicated on
on respect yeah if you've lost that
respect for me enough to step out
it's gone because you have to think
about in relationships the only time the
relationship's truly done is when the
woman says it's done the man can say
it's not gonna come back or are we clear
babes listen I'm sorry his dick's hard
he wants to do something you see when a
woman says she's done there's no return
end of end of so for a woman to do that
you must it's done you know what I'm
saying and for a man the most egregious
crime you can commit is is this loyalty
there's no there's no bigger crime
may I come back to your point you said I
never eat about you know how women say
uh he cheated once yeah you're right
because man doesn't cheat one if it's if
it's cheat one he's gonna come back to
again again again so man doesn't cheat
once in a while or once in his life just
if it is going there it's gonna come
back
do you ever ask why he cheated
a lot of times like girls don't give
their guys sex and are confused when
they trust me trust me I've been there
okay okay 25 of marriages
okay question then do you do you think
six for your husband is an obligation so
when he wants six you're gonna give it
to him
wait say again a sex in marriage or
relationship and obligation
you should enjoy it obligation like so
I'm saying every time he wants to bend
you over are you letting him put it
inside you is what I'm saying oh if
you're married or a relationship no it's
honestly guys about feelings like it's
about the Bible says no and he seeks it
elsewhere is that a problem you're gonna
say yes but see but that's that's messed
up
because they're what I'm saying I'm
saying because you're just thinking
about what you want because
what do you want from a man like what is
he obligated to for you in a
relationship well I'm saying loyalty is
up there trust loyalties up there that's
that's a must but then if you guys are
saying that no no for you yes obligation
from a man yeah that's for you but yeah
just those two things well that's one of
them I can't think and list them all up
but yeah the main one is loyalty and to
respect me love me all of that stuff
that's that's up there that's well what
if he says I'm only doing that for
someone that's my wife I'll respect you
but I'm out
you can't be loyal or respect me but you
want to be with me you only be
respectful and loyal to your wife
so then either you put a ring on this or
I'm gone that's it what if he said I'm
gone unless you give me sex on demand
I'm gone as well then you're gone
you don't think sex is a duty in
marriage but she just
like you keep changing it is it marriage
I'm usually talking in the context of
marriage
I've never been married I mean I I even
think in a relationship honestly if he's
not sleeping with anyone else yeah you
should give him sex whenever he wants
whatever he wants yeah
because like why should you go get it
because guys you guys want to [__] all
the time so if I'm saying like please
don't [__] other girls just [__] me like
then I should I should get back here
okay wait I understand that but then if
there's just a one day where it's like
I'm not in it right now or I'm on my or
whatever
does that mean that he now has a right
to go and have sex with someone
obviously it's not one day come on
that's what I'm saying but you guys are
making it sound I'll give you one day
not too I'll give you one day in that
too
if you missed work one day they might
give you a passive two days in a row you
might you might be getting a pink slip
that was the scenario that you gave us
earlier about
um your your mess with your man yeah and
work
I was about to say that yes every minute
feeling well
they got all colors they will still go
to work
a man actually is going to cheat or is
cheating because you didn't give it
enough yes
that's like you're not showing up to
work in your mouth they got a temp well
you're gone
at least
at least you're the job still there for
when you get back
at least they didn't fire you just to
tell them I just think that's the duty
to have sex with your man whenever he
wants it however you want yeah
whenever you want listen if you want to
have sex
guys guys before we go again and let's
just reiterate some rules I know we've
got some new people on the panel but
guys one at a time I cannot hear you
they can't hear you please let's do this
all right
foreign
[Laughter]
I have a question for you two ladies
because when Auntie's talking about that
earlier she was talking about it we were
like yeah if that's my man if that's my
husband why wouldn't I you two right now
your facial expression your body
language is
when she's talking about it it's like no
I wouldn't do that if he wants it I
wouldn't do that all the time
if if no but if if he wants sex all the
time unless you're a man or whatever
then fair enough have sex but the point
I'm trying to get at is you could be
giving him you could be throwing it back
do like you could be giving it to him
all day every day he will still go
somewhere else see someone has the
choice to cheat she's dead and I'll
still have sex with her even though my
girl is giving it to me every day okay
life's about trade-offs no no I'm saying
so like can I just I'll explain so life
is about trade-offs so you can either
pick a guy that other women want and no
he might cheat on you or you can pick a
guy a guy that no other women want and
he won't cheat on you but the thing is
girls pick the guys that other women
want to bang he might cheat but how
would how would you know you you you
know and the thing is like girls act
stupid like no that no I'm not I'm not
I'm not talking about you I'm not
talking about you girls will act stupid
like they don't know know this guy might
cheat like but they know they know what
like you you can feel it on a guy if he
gets a lot of girls honestly like if I
can't express my point of view I wasn't
like about uh the fact if I love that
man I will definitely uh sex with him
whenever he wants because I want it I
want it but if you actually
[Laughter]
talking about like I have two that's
another point I don't have to I want it
it's different like in a marriage it's
supposed to be like that I have designed
I want you because I love you because
there's something between us not because
you asked me and that's one of my duty
which is different I don't have duty if
for one day I'm sick and like I just add
the baby let's say man like you know I
agree with you I agree with you you know
the problem is I think a lot of women
are quite idealistic about future so a
lot of women think about as I am now in
a relationship when you've been there
for 30 years your feelings and emotions
they're going to be less you know what I
mean
I'm listening
if you and your woman having good sex
and she gets 20 years old or 30 years
older she said no I'm too old she's
talking rubbish banger
she's talking